cet appel à la nation du président bush
c'est d'autant plus important que depuis
le 11 septembre dernier
et bien la vie économique du pays
ralentit le courrier n'est plus
distribué qu'en faible quantité les
avions déserté bref
l'amérique ne peut pas continuer à vivre
à ce rythme etienne leenhardt à anyama
reportage cette salle est sans aucun
doute l'un des meilleurs baromètres des
grandes et des petites frayeurs de
l'amérique profonde jour et nuit
pompiers et policiers ils reçoivent les
appels d'urgence
depuis les attentats les responsables
ont bien noté une augmentation du nombre
des communications mais c'est surtout le
motif des appels qui a changé après le
bacille de charbon et les détournements
d'avion les habitants voient encore
aujourd'hui les terroristes et de la
poudre blanche un peu partout où on a
les appels de gens qui ont remarqué dans
leur quartier des hommes de type
oriental qui ne font rien de particulier
mais qui sont dessus serait depuis le 11
septembre
une personne a appelé parce qu'elle
avait trouvé de la poudre blanche sur sa
pelouse
elle n'était simplement pas au courant
que son jardinier était passé et avaient
répandu de l'engrais au nom de la même
angoisse il est toujours impossible pour
les responsables politiques américains
de recevoir du courrier en temps normal
quinze mille lettres sont distribués
chaque jour ici au congrès depuis les
enveloppes piégées au bacille de charbon
plus rien et les parlementaires se rabat
sur le fax et les messages internet pour
communiquer avec leurs électeurs
je suis certain que les gens qui
m'écrivent sont frustrés parce que je ne
réponds pas il croit sans doute que j'ai
reçu leur lettre ce qui n'est pas le cas
et puis dans cet immense pays la
conscience collective se méfient
désormais de l'avion sur cette ligne de
chemin de fer entre l'est et l'ouest des
états unis le trafic est toujours en
progression de 20% par rapport à la
période qui a précédé les attentats
ça me soulage un peu d'avancé
l'entourant ça me donne le temps de voir
que l'amérique se porte assez bien à la
gare j'ai une famille à la maison et
donc je me dis bon pourquoi prendre des
risques
retourner à une vie normale voilà une
ambition bien louable mais il faudra
sans doute beaucoup plus que des
discours pour que les habitants de la
première puissance mondiale se sentent à
nouveau en sécurité sur leur propre
territoire